patiently lebron james will pull  valenciunis away from the basket  now goes to work lebron right by him and  the layup  no problem for lebron james anthony  davis took his time and knocked it down  the shooter making the right decision  down the stretch oh jang lost the handle  turnover  again for memphis and now lebron off one  foot each team with a foul to give here  late clock for the lakers leading by a  point lebron backing down brooks  a little fade away is good lebron james  with a big shot for la  davis and lebron combining for the last  nine lakers points  now james got the ball in his hands the  whole possession and he'll stick another  one  lebron james run here by the lakers  grant  and you talked about their fourth  quarter efficiency  and lebron james and anthony davis just  take it over down the stretch here in  closing time  and this right here is just special i  mean this was actually really